so this is - back for some tactics
frenzy we've got ourselves a new mode
called time mode basically there's an
added time element you're not training
anymore this is real this is the real
deal yeah let's try it see what's what's
gonna happen I feel I already feel down
I feel like this is too difficult for me
but we'll see so random it's not a good
thing for me I don't like it
no nothing is random in life Fischer
random it's terrible but anyway Joker I
can't resist it mmm let's see
so Quincy 5 that stalemate mate in one
all good so far
take on c5 then give a check take back
the rook so far the puzzles are with
brute force and then I can do them
otherwise I cannot so I go king c1 no
safe square for the for the bishop
standard study stuff I've seen this one
rookie what right is it from one of your
games yeah Wow
did you make the puzzle this by the way
the head of streaming in the background
also known that's the hammer everybody
knows him some people love him I like
these ones take the Queen take the
bishop if you like they got me some some
easy ones this time you got the luck of
the draw the randomizer yeah exactly
haver
take this one Queen e7 and Queen d6 this
was a nice puzzle that was a very nice
person this one obviously you know ok
this is gonna be mating - Wow win the
rook I feel like I'm on a bit of a roll
now 13 in a row you can see the streak
on the 13 in a row
Queen g5 was that one of my games it
almost looks familiar
- I have no idea that looked at tricky
to me no that was wrong yeah of course
Bishop f2 was mate take Queen c1 and so
on but no need to cry over spilled milk
no did I think that was a mouse later I
don't count that one I don't count that
one
mating one back to the good stuff mating
- I was alike brute force this is got to
be mate no Jack Jack Jack and mate
I hate these ones where I don't know
where the the the pawns are are flowing
aha see Wow that was fine I was real
nice met him one I'm getting sure good
time yeah what a hell
oh not g6 exactly yeah you lose 10
seconds when you make a mistake yeah I
shouldn't make mistakes then that would
be the moral of the story
there should be safest mate Wow
take back the Queen sack the Queen and
Bishop T - yeah mate in one
Oh what am I supposed to be here before
threatening to pieces eight seconds
you're white you're white I'm white no
ah [ __ ] b6 whilst ailment okay
whatever 28 and that's just pretty far
behind the head of streaming with 36 it
says your best ever it's not true that's
my best that's your best ever
so my playing on my account yeah my mom
was way away way worse but then again
I'm not the head of streaming so how can
I even competes okay test it out for
yourself Scott yeah see if you can beat
mom this is 28 I'm sure you can but it's
also yeah I'm sure in a couple of weeks
I'll be able to to do 29
you